principled leaders need to think not
just about the impacts of their actions
on their own firm and in particular not
just on their own shareholders but the
impacts of those actions on society more
broadly one of the key features of the
new curriculum is a is a much increased
emphasis on leadership education in the
very first full quarter we expose the
students to critical analytical thinking
in in small seminar groups which really
encourages future leaders to think about
the really tough issues that leaders
will have to face in practice we also
asked the students in the fall to really
reflect on their own leadership styles
and skills as well as other leadership
styles that they might aspire to and to
think behaviorally about the skills that
they need to go from where they are now
to where they need to be so through
experiential learning as well as seminar
based discussions and conventional
classes in all of these ways we're
touching on various aspects of
leadership we have a world-class faculty
who not only in the classroom are able
to translate ideas from management but
they actually through their research and
through their writing create the ideas
in the first place
one of the extraordinary advantages we
have at Stanford is that we are on a
campus with all of the leading schools
not just the LED school of management
but of course lower education medicine
engineering and so on and one of our
really important goals is to continue to
open ourselves up to the rest of the
campus and to provide opportunities for
our students to engage with
extraordinary students not just in
management but in these other fields as
well
we now require every single student to
go to a country where they did not grow
up where they have not had significant
work experience preferably some time in
their first year or else shortly into
their second year and so students go out
of their comfort zone to countries that
they've never been before what we have
found which has far exceeded my
expectations is of course the student
has their own experience in these
countries but more importantly than that
each of them brings a different
experience back to the GSB there's an
natural marriage here between social
innovation and our students passion for
social innovation on the one hand and
the core frameworks and knowledge and
management approach that we teach in the
MBA program the mantra of the GSB of
course is change lives change
organizations change the world and one
of the ways we do that is by providing
an opportunity for students with a
passion to change the world through
social innovation to come to the GSB to
arm themselves with management
principles to use this platform and
their networks to then go out and make
significant social change in the world